à à
anh Alo ạ
anh alo mọi ngày để không ạ Alo
anh alo alo một ngày đúng
nghe tiếng Hàn bé quái mọi người bảo
mình nhé Alo Alo
anh alo
Anh em mình cứ chỉ mấy chục to lên sẽ cỡ
nhà nhé
Ừ
thì ta chưa đến buổi học cho mình on một
tiếng nhưng trước rồi mình à cứ ngồi đợi
Thôi mình đang định cho mọi người nghe
cái cái nhạc dạo này mình nghiện Cháu
trả lời quan học tập đâu giờ mình mình
thấy hay hay chia sẻ mọi người mọi người
xem nhé à
anh bay mình vừa chính to hết cỡ đó thì
mọi người thấy to quá ấy có gì
bé lại
Ừ để lại tình yêu nghỉ à
anh
[âm nhạc]
hiền lắm đừng nơi à
xanh em ấn gì rồi chờ xóa
một đôi này
có em tám chờ
đôi vai em vẫn mình góc cây thông Lương
khá bên kho gió đầu đau Xin nhân lời nói
em có anh tình người mai một góc ơi cùng
trao cành cây điều em muốn cùng anh
chiều nay lên sẽ đi đó đây
Hu hu
Con nhớ
là năm nữa à anh
Phúc Phúc Phúc năm nữa
vì sao cứ ngồi mãi ôm vẫn Phương giờ
chẳng còn có ai nhớ thương ngày xưa vắng
trôi cuối cùng Chỉ có tôi cánh bên em
đấy thôi Khê
rất là láng vẫn rơi khắp sân còn là chọn
đầy chút buồn Vầng anh đừng vội đến đây
đét trôi bốc hơn yên nơi đi tiên nước ta
đã áp cha cha à
[âm nhạc]
à à
Ừ Ok Ok mình vừa tóc input audio đấy ra
mình chưa quen cái này lắm
các bạn nghe tiếng cháu ổn hơn đúng
không ạ
a tiếp theo thì đến cái bài remix
Anh remix của online remix Tèo phạm với
Li Na đến mùng mấy sẽ thấy
ô hay hơn
[âm nhạc]
có 8 chờ
đôi vai vẫn khóc tóc đừng ra bên con gió
đầu đau chỉ nhân lời nói bóp em đừng
người mang khóc anh trao tình cay
muôn ngay trưa nay lên gian đó Đấy
bây giờ lỗi tôi ngồi đấy nhớ mãi cực đây
rồi đấy nhưng mà phải về Ra đây chơi rồi
đấy
trên được đấy ạ ạ Bây giờ tôi vẫn ngồi
đây chúng ta bảo kê đánh con anh truyền
thống đôi của tao hơi đấy đi Được cái
nhớ điện thoại trên bản đồ giấy
rồi Mai còn vẫn cứ trời chẳng còn có ai
để nhớ thương giờ vẫn trôi cuối cùng Chỉ
có tôi bên em
đấy thôi khi
rất là căng rồi nát giấc còn là chốn đây
chút buồn vầng tay
đến anh đã trôi về nơi yên nơi tình đôi
ta đã
xa xa
[âm nhạc]
em ạ
à à
em ạ cuối cùng là một bài to chính một
bạn DJ bạn đấy có vợ à mà remix lại à
[âm nhạc]
Anh cũng chưa thật đây đây đây đây đây
đây
thì có chứ con đấy à
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok thôi Tại vì mày cảnh nhạc các thử
cũng chuẩn bị vào học nha
Ừ vậy thì mình tranh thủ trả lời trước
các bạn có cô chat ở đây để mà
tí vợ vào Dậy Thì mình định là thỉnh
thoảng mình sẽ trả lời câu hỏi được thôi
Một Vì mình không thể luôn cho mình chạm
xem có hoạt trả lời và nó bị cảm mất mất
mạch tập trung ấy thì mình sẽ thường
xuyên xem lại mình thì sẽ không Mình sẽ
chắn mình sẽ xem lại tất cả buổi học
mình mình số kinh nghiệm cũng nhờ Xem
mãi bình luận các bạn và tổng hợp đồng
nhưng ở đây các bạn đang thấy cái tổng
hợp tất cả câu hỏi từ buổi livestream
muốn trước mà mình chưa kịp trả lời thì
mình sẽ hôm nay mình sẽ trả lời hết lại
tất cả cái đấy cũng như mình sẽ Ôn lại
các bạn
cho nên là các bạn thắc mắc gì thì sao
rồi kể cả bị trôi trôi bình luận thì
không không phải lo vì buổi sau cái gì
mình sẽ trả lời các bạn nhé nghe ạ Nên
là các bạn nên học và hỏi nhiều đúng
không
à à Chưa chưa học bây giờ đã đến giờ rồi
đúng không nên mình cứ chuẩn bị tinh
thần mà thôi
à à
ở tp hay node.js được nhiều người dùng
vậy ạ thực tế là hồi mình hồi mình
nghiên cứu thì ra là nó lâu lắm rồi mới
thấy cha nhé PPF nấu chị em này
mức độ phổ biến của P là thật
có 6 chữ 696 so với node.js này đúng
không nước CS thì mình thấy nốt sẽ trở
nên tao định mà mọi người nhảy sang để
vương quốc khác chút mình không thấy nói
gì anh ấy nó phát triển lớn hơn p đâu
tại TP nó vẫn đứng đầu về tạo ra website
hơn à
ở
đây mọi người sẽ thấy cái thằng pê Thực
ra làm đó là cung nó là ngôn ngữ được sử
dụng cũng rất là nhiều nhưng mà đồng
thời cũng rất nhiều lập trình viên ghét
nó cái gì vì lúc đầu thì đúng là dễ học
nhưng mà nhược điểm là nó dễ nó không
chặt chẽ nên thành ra là vì sao học
chuyên sâu nó sẽ rất trễ sẽ sinh ra rước
nhiều cái lỗi loa Dần hay các thứ thế
nên là cũng
anh cũng rất nhiều người phàn mày nó
nhưng đồng thời chính vì nhiều người
phản lò làm và hỏi đáp với nó nhiều
thành ra là cộng đồng hỗ trợ p cũng rất
là đông các bạn tra Google lúc về bất kỳ
gần như bây rồi Gần như ở các câu hỏi
nói cho trên Google nó đều sẽ có câu trả
lời các bạn ạ
Anh ở chưa đến 8 giờ nên mình chỉ đang
nói qua thôi
ạ Bây giờ đang trả lời câu hỏi qua hơi
thông cảm mình ngồi đợi Tiến hồ rồi
nhưng
ừ ừ
em chưa dậy đâu các bạn nhá chưa dậy đây
mình Bây giờ mình cứ quay video trước để
các bạn có gì cứ xem lại đã á Không ngon
không cần quay buổi buổi video này cũng
sẽ tự động ghi lại rồi mà các bạn cứ xem
lại thôi đúng không em 27 tuổi có muộn
để học lập trình không Ờ câu này khá là
chung chung với khá nhiều bạn trái ngành
này có nhiều Bạn gấu bạn Mình ở lại bạn
Mình gần đây là mình lôi kéo được bốn
người bạn
ở cùng 597 theo ngành này và mình còn
gặp mình cũng từng dạy lớp bổ túc buổi
tối
cho mì anh chị mấy anh chị để có
mình nhớ điển hình nhất là có anh ờ anh
đấy sinh nói chung là hơn 30 tuổi rồi
anh ấy lái xe tải
từ ngày đó kẹo lao động cũng không phải
lao động những kiểu bằng trí óc lắm
nhưng mấy người muốn đội nhà nhanh muộn
kiểu thái độ sự nghiệp các thứ tư anh
đến học bổ túc và anh ấy
học
nhà cách trường hơn 20 cây một tuần 3
buổi mỗi buổi 2 tiếng
Anh ấy đi toàn đến gần một trong những
người đến đầu tiên luôn và anh ấy rất là
cần củ và những cái người như thế hoặc
trái nhàng thế tuy họ Khởi đầu có thể xa
chậm chậm này vừa chậm vừa không có cái
góc bằng bọn mình và đôi khi dễ nghị
nhiều trí vân vân Nhưng mà họ có cái chí
có cái kẹo động lực cao hơn rất rất
nhiều nó thành ra là
Em à anh đấy là một trong những cái mà
mình vẫn thức một cái Điền hình mà mình
thường này nhắc đi nhắc ạ
Thế này là các bạn hãy bỏ qua về các độ
tuổi đi học nhưng không nói việc là học
cái này thì các bạn sẽ là mày luôn những
nhưng mà ai cũng nên biết qua về công
nghệ thông tin về mà anh có nhìn khác về
công nghệ thông tin này và mình làm việc
mọi thứ sẽ kiểu sẽ thông minh khoa học
hơn bởi vì bây giờ là cái gì mà áp dụng
và công nghệ thông tin nữa rồi
Ờ equal nó dùng trong chính cái việc của
họ SQL nó là ngôn ngữ truy vấn dữ liệu
nên là nó phù hợp trong những cái công
việc liên quan đến kiểu phân tích dữ
liệu
Ừ địt âm lượng nhỏ mình nói hết cỡ rồi
mà đây để mình thấy xác rồi nhé Tại mình
chưa mua được cái
giá treo mic thế nên là bây giờ mình
phải di sát vào cái bàn thì mới nói được
to ấy à
à à
ừ ừ
ờ ờ Mun thiết kế cơ sở liệu đấy là một
trong những môn cũng rất là quan trọng
nó nó chính là kéo nó là dạy cách tạo
database tạo thấy bồ cái thứ mà mình
cũng sẽ dạy qua ở cái mô nasware này
ashworth nó ngôn ngữ truy vấn cái cơ sở
dữ liệu đấy còn môn thiết kế cơ sở rượu
hay là môn cấu trúc dữ liệu giải thuật
đó là một trong những môn rất là hay để
mà kiểu tối ưu và nó lại là một trong
những môn rất là khó cũng như là chỉ khó
nhưng lương nó cũng sẽ rất là cao cải
lương mà hôm trước mình bảo là 5000 đô
cái đã ta bây akitech là kiến trúc sư
cơ sở lý ảo ấy thì chính là nhiều những
cái môn cấu trúc dữ liệu giải thuật và
môn hướng dẫn về thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu
đấy à
à à
Anh ở bạn muốn xây dựng
một trang web thì nên dùng ngôn ngữ nào
á thì pp thì là một ngôn ngữ lập trình
khá là tương đối dễ để mà tạo hóa còn
thực ra là bạn thích ngôn ngữ nào cũng
có thể làm được bây giờ để giả web bạn
chạy tự nhiên ở bọn nó sẽ có ưu và nhược
điểm của từng cái thì bây giờ mình bạn
mới thì mình nghĩ à dùng những cái ngôn
ngữ nó dễ đúng không thì sẽ dễ ra sau đó
thì bạn cảm thấy nó có thể chạy chậm hay
là nó không ổn thì gì đấy thì các bạn
chuyển ngôn ngữ khác vẫn được vì ngôn
ngữ lập trình nó nó rất nhiều nét tương
đồng đấy do mà thì các bạn không cần
phải tranh luận là việc các bạn nên học
ngôn ngữ nào mà các bạn chỉ cần chuyên
sâu một cái ngôn ngữ về các bạn nhảy
sang ngôn ngữ khác nó dễ à
A testo có cần vững axwell Không anh lại
cũng một câu hỏi rất hay này
tester gần đây ở công ty mình cũng được
tuyệt và mình cũng được nghe nghe lọ là
về cái vụ phỏng vấn đó là Ừ nếu mà Peter
mà biết về quê ấy để mà test những câu
những cái để mà truy vấn các theo hướng
thì
nói chung là rất là Út nói chung là
giống như kiểu ôm em bảo là cái tơ biết
lập trình có tốt không ấy thì đương
nhiên là có bởi vì mình sẽ biết content
những cái gì hơn và mình sẽ làm được hơi
đa-zi-năng thì mình không nhảy vào lập
trình nó nhá Nhưng mà mình sẽ kiểu biết
cách thì mà test thì mình nghĩ là sẽ giữ
ổn hơn
nhờ có thầy hiệu trưởng đang ở ngoài đấy
Anh đáp có cần học cơ sở dữ liệu không ở
fef2 Nói chung là cái này vừa nãy mình
có trả lời rồi đó là có lập trình bác
cái này thì các bạn cần nên biết người
SQL để Bá truy vấn trừ khi công ty các
bạn đưa các bạn toàn bộ những cái có sẵn
rồi các bạn chỉ việc chạy thôi thì nó
khác nhưng mà bây giờ rất ít công ty có
đủ kẹo nó phải đủ giữa to thì nó mới cho
sẵn các bạn cứ thế còn không chính bạn
là người sẽ phải ghi những việc đấy à ờ
ờ cơ sở liệu Phi quan hệ thì mình cũng
chưa đọc vào nên là mình sẽ không dạy
các bạn được
ừ ừ
I will arrive có khác FL không ạ ạ
acculite Hôm trước cho bạn có xem được
thì abberline này tại mcleod đây ở những
màn áp nhé
Wow dri đúng không
Máy này
và cái nhìn đang dạy ở ở trên máy của
mình đó là Microsoft Word
Microsoft Word thì tất cả cái này hóa
dẫn chế tạo web
nó đều lại queo nhưng mà nó sẽ khác nhau
từ một tí một tí
khác nhau một tí thì mà cái việc khác
này thì các bạn
sẽ phải họp thêm một tí để biết được mà
khác nhau như nào còn không chủ yếu nó
với các bạn vẫn rất giống nhau Nó điều
ép em à à
à à
I spit on đ c + + rồi ok Nói chung là
bây giờ bình luận cũng bắt đầu sẽ ra từ
rồi nhiều rồi Mình mình không muốn À bữa
hôm nay chị mua trả lời bình luận sớm
như vậy bây giờ đầu tiên là mình
anh xem hộ hôm nay đúng không
Bữa hôm nay là về Pascal cơ bản những
câu lệnh cơ bản à
à
mục lục của hôm nay là ôn lại buồn trước
này và trả lời những câu hỏi từ Bộ hôm
trước để mà hãng đây nhờ một cách để ôn
lại đúng không sẽ trả lời hết tất cả
những câu hỏi tôi buổi trước tổng cộng
mà hơn cũng hơn 40 câu cá và sẽ nói qua
các công cụ thực hành bữa trước được ra
mình có nhắc rồi nhưng mà nhiều bạn
không nhớ thì hôm nay mình sẽ nhắc lại
mình sẽ không hướng dẫn các bạn chi tiết
về cái này lắm Bởi vì thì ca cái này các
bạn cũng nên chịu khó phải cha có rất
nhiều video hướng dẫn từ a đến z các bạn
vì cái này thì ra nó cũng chỉ nek thôi
thỉnh thoảng sẽ có vài cái bốc Nó có thể
trên máy các bạn cài đặt có vấn đề gì
đấy thì các bạn để họp inbox hỏi mình
hòa cũng chịu khó cha vì ngành lập trình
này chửi ngành Công nghệ thông tin này
chủ yếu là các bạn phải trao rất tốt các
bạn là
không thể nào mà cứ gặp lỗi thì các bạn
chịu được đấy là nhiều đấy sẽ là rào cản
các bạn các bạn em ăn gì có bạn phải tra
các bạn không biết từ khóa thì tra để
các bạn thể hỏi mình để gần như là thế
đi làm cũng sẽ đi làm các bạn cũng sẽ
không thể hỏi liên tục kể người
hỏi liên tục người khác được các bạn
cùng ngắm chị không biết được từ khóa
trong Google thì các bạn hỏi người đấy
để người đưa tài liệu các bạn để các bạn
biết cách tra thôi
tiếp theo những câu lệnh cú pháp cơ bản
của CPU D tí mình sẽ Dạ giải thích các
bạn sailed là gì nhé và cuối cùng là trả
lời câu hỏi trả lời câu hỏi cuốn buổi
trưa đi
ở đầu tiên là mình cũng sẽ mở cái mà hôm
trước mình mình đang đang làm rồi đúng
không ạ
nghe
tiếng mic của mình đang thu Nó hơi hơi
ngại thế nên là thỉnh thoảng các bạn sẽ
nghe vài tiền cái gì đó hơi lạ á
Thế em định mở lại bốn trước nhé
an apple
à à
ở đây đó
Thì hôm trước đầu tiên là mình tạo ra
tay đúng không Sau đó mình sử dụng cái
tên này nếu mà các bạn không tạo ra đó
Bây giờ mặc định và nó sẽ database cả
Master này thì tao không tốt các bạn nên
tạo hình data base để mà làm công việc
của mình ở trên chưa nhỏ ra từ một thư
mục
ờ ờ
được đầu tiên là các bạn sẽ tạm bảng
đúng không có bạn hãy lưu lại thông tin
của sinh viên đấy có tên cột này xong
ngồi kiểu dữ liệu của cột này xong rồi Ờ
đây là độ dài lớn nhất của cái chuỗi
đúng không
Thì ở đây đây kiểu in có bạn hỏi kiểu y
vậy Sao không mở ngoặc có ghi độ dài lớn
nhất giống như là kiểu chuỗi thì đúng
các bạn để ý cái đấy khá tinh ý thì kiểu
in thì mặc định nó sẽ là hai mũ 31 - 1
xấp xỉ hơn ạ hơn 2 tỷ
ý chính sau là từ Dương âm 2 tỷ cho đến
Dương 2 tỷ lãi đấy Kiểu in nó mặc định
là như thế nhưng các bạn không cần phải
điền Còn nếu mà các bạn muốn ghi cụ thể
là kiểu muốn quyết nó ví dụ là mình chỉ
trong một khoảnh bé thôi gì đấy thì nó
có thêm những cái mong trước mình có nói
như nó thai nhi nè than y này hoài xót
yêu bạn thì nhớ không cần mà Thế ở trong
nhà nhưng không có không không có medium
hãng gì vậy Cái này các bạn cha cha thêm
thì nhớ Ôi cái đấy thì lại hơi tí chuyên
sâu mình sẽ không đề cập cụ thể nào thì
ra mình không nhớ có rất nhiều cái gì
mày nói thẳng là cho dù kể cả lập trình
viên rất nhiều năm có những cái mình
không mơ động đến thì hoặc là rất ít
động đến thì mình không cần phải nhớ
anh Bởi vì có nhiều bạn tính hơi bị hiểu
hối trước mình cũng thấy mình cầu toàn
mà thành ra là kiểu học ngành Công nghệ
pin này sẽ bị cái khó chịu và rất nhiều
cá mình không biết mình cứ tra Google
mình hỏi xong rồi mình kiểu bị choáng
ngợp với kiến thức quá tải của nó vì sao
mình nhận ra một điều đó là không phải
tất cả những kiến thức mình cần phải
biết có nhiều cái là các bạn cứ làm đã
rồi các bạn hiểu sao hoặc là con nó hiển
nhiên là một cộng một bằng hai rồi hạn
chế việc là cả mình bị quá tải cái nước
quá nó ra nào giống như ấy à các bạn mở
cái ứng dụng lên rồi các bạn tự thắc mắc
là tại sao nó mở lên được Tại sao nó màu
trắng còn màu đen lại cái gì đấy Vân nó
bị quá tải kiến thức và các bạn kiến
thức cả đấy các bạn trá dụng được đâu cả
thì giờ nó bị thừa đúng không nên là
tôi có những cái mình sẽ cảm thấy nó
không hẳn là quan trọng mình sẽ mình sẽ
nói với bạn là nó không quan trọng để
các bạn tránh bị kiểu sau ngã mất tập
trung vào những cái đấy ạ
anh ấy sau đó mình chạy câu lệnh Insert
để mà thêm sinh viên vào này thì đây
mình phải ghi lại mình một có hai trường
có 2 trường hợp này mình có thể ghi đó
mình có thể hiện tất cả các cột ngay để
mình hiểu là truyền tương ứng cột này
của cột này cột này với con này của hai
con này đúng không
Hay mình xóa xóa cả này đi như này mình
vẫn có thể Insert tưởng như bình thường
nhưng mà nóng sẽ có nhược điểm tím mình
sẽ giải thích ờ
ở đây mình thêm chữ N đằng trước để mà
lưu lại viết được có dấu đúng không Đấy
xo có bạn thắc mắc là tại sao tuổi nó nó
lại không nằm trong cái dấu nháy
bởi vì à à
anh Bởi vì nó số số lần được ta không
cần phải để chân nhái không cần nói nhá
tự tức là vẫn có thể đạt được nó không
sao cả đấy chưa
Còn cái này thì vẫn là số nhưng mà nhưng
chỗ mình còn nói cái này số điện thoại
bạn chất nó chuỗi bởi vì nó câm số không
bằng đầu thế nên là thì nên là các bạn
vẫn phải để sống chuỗi phải để trong dấu
nháy tiếp theo là sao Này xếp sao Này
bạn chết là điểm mà xà lách tất cả các
cục mình đỡ phải mất công ghi lại bơi đồ
tất cả cột ở đây đúng không Thì này để
mở slack thì bạn chỉ cần xếp sao Thôi có
bạn hỏi là có ký tự khác ở trong này
không thì về sau họ có thể buổi buổi sau
nữa thì mình sẽ dạy các bạn thêm một vài
ký tự nữa ở trong này
Thế còn bạn hỏi tại sao là sao mà không
là ký tự khác thì cái này liên quan đến
We can này các bạn thích thì tra ngoài
khác ở trong trong svideo được chưa ạ
Ừ đúng rồi ai rất nhiều bản ghi đúng
không Đây yên tâm mình còn nốt ở đây đó
mình sẽ trả lời hết các bạn nhé này lần
lượt từng cái một nhá
đầu tiên à
ờ ờ đầu tiên là địa chỉ thì mình đi lưu
như thế nào đúng không Dữ liệu kiểu phân
cấp mình không biết được mới hiểu đúng
câu hỏi bạn ấy không nhưng mà hình như
bạn ấy hỏi địa chỉ mình lưu như thế nào
địa chỉ thì thì các bạn lưu đày mình sẽ
mở Excel cho các bạn xem qua đã
ship.io này à
ở địa chỉ giả sử của mình là
a123 timecity
gì đấy ví dụ là
ở Hoàng Mai Vậy thì như thế
Hà Nội này
rồi Việt Nam trở lại ạ
ừ ừ
đề
thi
thì kiểu như này các bạn thể phân rõ và
cụ thể thành hằn những cái cột giâm
giống như là số nhà
là 123 này
tên đường này đến phố gì đấy Gọi street
đúng không Chị sẽ timecity em ạ
và
cuộn này cái sau đó thì đến tỉnh thành
phố đúng không sau đó đến quốc gia là ạ
Đấy thì các bạn sẽ phân cấp ra thành
những cái nhỏ hơn nha đề mà các bạn sẽ
quản lý đề về sau Tìm kiếm mình muốn tìm
kiếm theo tỉnh Hai tìm kiếm nơi quận 2
thậm chí Tìm kiếm theo tên đường thì nó
sẽ ra rẽ đúng không Sao đương nhiên là
vì sau các bạn nếu mà là một lấy ra đầy
đủ thông tin thì các bạn chứ nối tất cả
động đấy lại với nhau thôi cái
có thai bị các bạn sẽ lưu lại các cụ
ngày cả cụ như này sẽ rất khó là tìm
kiếm gì chứ nếu ấy theo ý của bạn đấy
câu hỏi là như thế thì chán mình trả lời
rồi
những quét lớn cần lưu dữ liệu thông tin
người dùng trình sử dụng SQL 2 mép
ios3 cụ thể đây sẽ là Microsoft Word
đúng không Thì mình mới tra làm our you
big Company này chị ở đây sẽ ra rất rất
nhiều công ty ở đây Các bạn thấy tên là
khá quen thuộc làm Uber này Pinterest
này Thậm chí Facebook cũng sẽ dùng
Ờ nhưng mà còn tra máy ép cao à Kệ
Microsoft Word sử dụng bởi nhiều công ty
thì mình thấy danh sách nói ít hơn bởi
vì ashworth là hình như nhớ không làm gì
nhưng Mất phí thì ra là ít công ty dùng
hơn đấy là một cái hoặc cái thứ hai của
nó đó là Chính vì mất phí các lập trình
viên sử dụng máy quen nhiều hơn thành ra
là cái lượng lập trình viên dùng gọi
lượng nguồn nhân lực đúng không nào
giống như kiểu nguồn Nhân lực bây giờ sử
dụng hệ điều hành Windows nhiều hơn
linus cho nó thì nên là các công ty cần
phải cài hệ điều hành đi đâu rồi ạ gì
đấy
thì lượng lập trình viên máy quen nhiều
hơn thành ra lá kiểu các công ty sẽ sử
dụng cái anh nhiều hơn nhưng mà Mai kia
workwear về các bạn nhược điểm là nó
không dùng được ở trong
cơ sở dữ liệu của
nó lưu lại nhiều dụng máy vào nó chỉ phù
hợp cho những cái phần mềm mà ở tầm 1
triệu một triệu 12 triệu Bạn ghi độ lại
thôi hạn chế việc lưu lại như ông tin
quá các bạn là một trang web kiểu bình
thường như kiểu đã
tin tức hay Giải trí gì ấy thằng Trung
Hoa trang web quản lý sinh viên thì ra
nó không lên là nổ một triệu
Ừ thì còn được Nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn
muốn lưu lại nhiều hơn thì các bạn phải
cân nhắc
chỗ đây thì bạn này có thắc mắc hay chỉ
đơn giản là
tại sao chỗ này mình phải xuống dòng
thực tế là mình chẳng việc gì phải xuống
dòng tả chạy qua mình inter xuống dòng
để các bạn nhìn tiện thôi các bạn sẽ
thấy là mình cốt của mình nó cũng hơi
mang thì uống để cho nó dễ nhìn dễ cậu
sẽ đọc anh đúng không ạ a Kotex thì sao
thấy hình như cái này liên quan việc
futech có phải học fio2 không thực tế
mình có bởi vì nó có bác em thì cần nên
học
Anh bắt em có cần Giọt giọt quy hoạch
động quy hợp quy hoạch động hay là Toán
thì thực tế là không phải không phải bác
cái nào cần phải học trên sau vì nó trừ
khi các bạn làm liên quan đến Kiểu cái
quản lý cơ sở liệu này hay à Hay là cậu
các bạn là mi ai thì đương nhiên các bạn
sẽ phải do thuật toán
tự học word để làm những việc gì thì cái
này nasware thì học các wed thì các bạn
đã làm ổn thì cái bên bác em rồi
bị bên bác nên cần người nó và những cái
ngành nghề liên quan đến kiểu phân tích
dữ liệu có thể thử thì các bạn cản càng
chú trọng về bên Bắc à Ai quen này hơn
Ừ
cái vừa nãy mình trả lời rồi đúng không
đấy nếu mà tên người nó ngoài mà à mà
không có dấu như tiếng Việt thì không
cần thêm chữ ngờ thì cao tùy bởi vì Giả
sử giống như có bạn hỏi ở dưới này tiến
chung này Đấy Tiếng Trung thì hay ở
những cái tiếng nó là không phải trong
bảng chữ cái là tinh ý thì các bạn đều
phải thêm chữ N lần trước tự nhiên Đương
nhiên là bảng chữ cái Latinh kết hợp cả
thêm những cái kí tự đặc biệt
Ừ thì thì các bạn không phải thêm chữ Ờ
nhưng mà một khi một các bạn có những
cái chữ giống như tiếng Nhật sang tiếng
Trung chữ được gây nhé văn đoạn văn thì
các bạn phải thêm ký tự N lần trước một
vì nâu này không phải mỗi gõ tiếng Việt
mà lâu thì gõ được unicol tất cả những
cái những cái ký sự không nằm trên bàn
phím Các Bạn
Ừ
cái này có hỏi nó hơi ngoài lời một tí
cái này thì ra bởi vì mình mới dậy gần
đây à
số điện thoại và mình từng đi Dậy đi Dậy
rồi thì thực ra có nhiều bạn thích kiểu
chứng nhận gửi lời mời kết bạn Thực ra
thì các bạn cứ thoải mái inbox Minh mình
ai mà từng inbox mình sẽ thấy mình rất
dễ tính và trả lời nhanh nhất khi có thể
nghe các bạn không cần phải gửi mời kết
bạn mình
theo dõi mình từ các chẳng cần luôn
thì các bạn chỉ cần à
Thì thắc mắc gì nhờ đến mình ở đâu rồi
Ừ mình đang thắc mắc giữa Vì sao có lệnh
cần khoảng chóng mình có nói đấy đúng
không
Mình học ngành gì à Mình học bạ ngành
Công nghệ thông tin lập trình thôi mình
không Bách Khoa cơ khí trái ngành chuyển
sang đâu
giới tính để làm một đúng không Nhưng
mình có nói không hôm trước
à à
khi còn nóng trước và giới tính mình nên
lưu lại lại ít hơn bởi vì mình ghi nếu
mà mình chỉ có mỗi nam và nữ thì mình
việc lưu lại trỗi thế này là tra 3 giờ ạ
Có ông Hôm trước bảo chơi hàm Tech như
này lại lớn quá thì mình lưu lại dặn bit
theo kiểu là một và không thì nó sẽ nhẹ
hơn rất nhiều nó sẽ nhẹ hơn cho dữ liệu
rất nhiều
hướng dẫn cách thiết kế thì mình sẽ cất
nhắc được việc ở dạy dạy các bạn với
thiết kế ra bay Nhưng cái này liên quan
đến việc chắc là phải đến pp thì mình
họp xong mình một mình sẽ dạy các bạn vì
xây dựng một cái trang web cơ bản thì
mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn với thiết kế
database
các bạn dùng bạn bạn nào cũng được bạn
càng mới càng tốt nhé
ừ ừ
ở quê Online Vừa nãy mình có nói về cái
sự khác giống và khác rồi đúng không Đây
Rồi nhanh lên anh ơi Ờ Thực ra cái này
Hôm trước mình hơi cãi nhau ở đâu phần
chat này ờ ờ
ẩm thực tế là cũng na ná giống như các
bạn có bảo lại dạy kiến thức ít thế nào
cần dạy nhiều hơn các thứ thứ dạy hẳn
hai tiếng thứ đứng ở cũng coi Ý trái
chiều là anh dậy chậm thế này là em thấy
ổn rồi các hư hư các thực tế là
xe mình nghĩa là mình dậy chậm sau đó
thì các bạn to nhanh thì nó dễ hơn vì
đây là video còn hơn là dễ nên quá rồi
có nhiều bạn không treo được vì với các
bạn ở đây ở dậy rất là cơ bản đúng không
dạ dành cho người chưa biết gì mà là
ngon thế nên là cũng có nhược điểm là có
nhiều bạn mà kiểu biết được một chút rồi
bạn đấy muốn vào học những cái mà các
bạn ấy cần học thôi có rất nhiều bạn hỏi
mình thấy mà ví dụ là em biết cái này
rồi bao giờ anh dậy đến phần này hả Anh
thì thức a Mình cũng chưa xác định được
bởi vì để theo tiến độ các bạn xem mà
hôm đấy các bạn có học có sự hiểu được
không Hay vân vân vân thì mình điều
chỉnh lại thế Mình không chắc được là
giáo án của mình là bao nhiêu buổi hay
là
nên dậy đến dậy đến hôm nào sẽ ra buổi
thứ bao nhiêu mình không Sắp lại được vụ
đấy
ừ ừ
khi tách giống xchinh không nhỉ Đúng là
tách nó về các bạn thì nó là sự Trinh nó
chuỗi nhưng mà nó sẽ lưu lại cái Độ lớn
của nó lớn hơn vậy đấy lý do các bạn
không khai báo độ lớn cho tách
bu lần là kiểu chu Phone đúng ngòi bút
lần là kìa chú phone chọn này thế nhưng
mà với máy tính thì chú Phone nó sẽ ở
một vài không thôi nên không cần không
cần phải ghi Chu Phone và ghim 10 thôi
khi xe công an mình sẽ được rồi không có
cách nào để đi xuất thêm từ tệp Excel
thẳng và Apple không ạ
Cái này các bạn có thể tục tung hoàn
toàn lập lập trình để làm điều đấy
có có tool để hỗ trợ những cái cậu Demi
rớt hàng và mình việc các bạn Excel nó
cũng là một ashworth nhé Hôm trước mình
có
mình có làm cho các bạn đã phải trách
nhiệm với đấy rồi
khi phân tích về xác định quan hệ trong
các thực thể thì cái này liên quan đến
về sau mình dậy thiết kế ra tao bay này
nó giới tính dùng được tách không các
bạn đây vừa nãy mình có nói giới tính
chung cách thì nó quá thừa dữ liệu đúng
không
thì
tại sao phải bôi đen trước khi chạy hôm
trước có rất nhiều bạn kiểu Chạy
ghi cốt từ đầu đến cuối do mày chạy từ
ga thế không tốt đúng không các bạn phải
có cốt để đâu Xong rồi chạy đúng mỗi cái
đoạn đấy thì top thế nó mới chuẩn à
Ừ cái câu của bạn là do bạn đấy chưa
hiểu nên bạn bị ngâm này
ở học kỳ Học FeO xong không đủ để mà lại
thiết kế một cái chương trình gì cả Bởi
vì eo keo nó không phải ngôn ngữ lập
trình học our Xong bây giờ nếu mà các
bạn chỉ học mỗi queo ấy một là các bạn
theo ngành chuyên sâu về bên em quen này
hay là các bạn làm bên kế toán là cảm
rất mạnh cần làm với Cha rất nhiều thì
các bạn biết cách để mà gõ Excel tìm
kiếm hay là nói chung là mọi thứ sẽ tốt
hơn giống như bây giờ mình nhảy sang làm
kế toán mình tự tin là mình sử dụng
Excel ngon hơn tất cả các bạn đây vì
mình gõ nhanh hơn này cũng đi làm mình ạ
biết những câu lệnh của sco để tối ưu
việc thống kê tính toán
à à
ở những điểm của cái này chả cái này đi
phỏng vấn dễ xịt Đúng rồi bởi vì atwell
thực là nếu mà các bạn mà chỉ làm biết
về mỗi Speed có bạn đi phỏng vấn ấy thì
các bạn phải có nhiều năm kinh nghiệm
chứ nó rất ít khi tuyển thực tập của vì
nó là nó kiến trúc sư để mở làm cái gì
đó rất phức tạp đằng sau mà Thì ra là
cái ngành này thì giống như mình vào
lương khởi điểm là 5000 đô Tức là không
chỉ có bạn nhiều năm kinh nghiệm lắm ấy
đúng không
có bao nhiêu buổi dậy thì mình vừa nói
đó là mình không xác định được sẽ có
tổng cộng bao nhiêu buổi đúng không
Em có cách nào để nhập nhiều lần không
vừa nãy có bạn lại hỏi lại mình cái này
mình sẽ trả lời các bạn luôn nhé cách để
nhập thông tin nhiều lần thì các bạn sẽ
cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy hai giờ các bạn
sẽ phải điền tiếp thôi là sự như bây giờ
Điềm tiếp mày đúng không
là nhà trả nợ
mọi người nhìn shop đúng không
à À không không Bây giờ nó sẽ báo lỗi
tại sao Vì à
anh Bởi vì em mình chưa yêu cái tao bay
này đã yêu xong rồi thì bây giờ mày có
vẻ tao bay các bạn này chính xác lại đó
được gọi sẽ nhắc lại
anh đang đâu rồi đúng không Đấy là một
lúc để xuất được nhiều thông tin đi
hai người không không có mặc nói rồi này
à à
thì các bạn đang học ở chính trưởng ấy
thử ta học thêm của mình rất tốt mà kẹo
vừa học vừa thực hành được ấy nó sẽ
không bị chán không bị ảnh hưởng gì mà
còn tốt lành khác
em có danh sách kiến thức sẽ học trong
một buổi không Thực ra là mình cũng như
mì nói mình khuya mình cũng đi dạy rồi
những có giáo án ở nhưng mà cái này tùy
theo các bạn xem tùy điều chỉnh thế nào
mình sẽ chưa công công công bố được một
cái gì cụ thể trong một buổi mà từng
buổi mình sẽ có slide để nói qua là bộ
âm đấy sẽ dậy thì thôi
anh em mình là lại rồi má lốp cái cái vụ
mà tại sao mình lại chọn rốt Thay bồ như
này bởi vì mỗi khi mình sửa cái gì thêm
thêm cột hoa đổi tên con thay đổi bất kỳ
trong bảng ấy thì thường là các bạn có
một là các bạn phải xóa cả vàng đi để
bạn tạo lại nhưng mà thường là vì sao
các bạn sẽ không nên làm điều này
3000 chuyện ở các bạn ngồi xóa cả bạn đi
với nó sẽ bay hết toàn bộ thông tin thì
bạn sẽ phải sẽ có cái khái niệm mà enter
p.bồ để mà sửa cụ thể từng cột này hay
là từng cái gì đó thay đổi tên bảng này
gì đó
Thì cái này nó mình nghĩ là cái kiến
thức này lại mình lại ít khi dùng em thì
ra là mình sẽ không dậy đi sâu các bạn
vẫn đây này vì về các bạn các bạn vì sao
làm bên bác and ấy còn nếu mà chỉ cần
biết qua cơ bạn ấy thì các bạn rất ít
khi được chạy mình cái lận đấy vì nó rất
là nguy hiểm thế nên hãy ra là cũng
không cần phải nắm rõ cái lắm
ở đây vì sao mình sẽ dạy các bạn về tại
mục website cơ bản đúng không từ đầu đến
cuối nên chắc là cái biết rồi Tại mình
sẽ ngoại hợp lại kiến thức đúng không
cài đặt khi mày cài gì đó thì tuyệt đối
không nhắm mắt mà bầm nách Đúng rồi cái
không liên qua một tí nhưng mà Bởi vì
hôm trước mà mình bảo các bạn cài đặt
mới gì đó Con lãi kiểu suy nghĩ đúng
không thực tế như thế đương nhiên là bây
giờ có nhiều phần mềm kiểu nó chèn thêm
quảng cáo nhưng đây cũng là một cái rất
hay ở bên lập trình đó là các bạn lên
hẳn trang chủ của các trang bên lập bên
bên đấy những ví dụ ở các công cụ phần
mềm này hoặc các bạn lên hàm trang chủ
thôi các bạn tải về các bạn sẽ không ngờ
dính quảng cáo và đưa nhẹ không ngờ
virus và gần như là miễn phí đấy cái lợi
của bên công nghệ thông tin đó là tất cả
những cái nguồn tài nguyên các bạn đều
miễn phí và nó đều không có kiểu nó đều
không có cài dám thêm cái gì cả không
cài thêm giáp Vì cả nên các bạn yên tâm
mà bấm nách không phải lo gì cả
Ừ nhưng mà nó thì nó sẽ hiển thị cả lỗi
gì đó liên quan đến máy các bạn cài có
vấn đề thì các bạn phải nhớ
có phải gõ luôn đầy đủ đoạn lỗi đấy Lên
Google để tìm kiếm nhé thương phải bấm
nách xong rồi thấy lỗi thì thôi kệ thôi
Ừ mình không điện bên nấu Apple nên mình
không không chạy được đúng không
xe tải celexa là chọn tất cả trong bảng
sinh viên để xuất ra câu này không phải
câu hỏi nhưng đây là câu trả lời cho một
bạn khác Và mình thấy thực ra là cái này
nó hơi sai một tí thì hôm nay mình sẽ
giải thích các bạn Tại sao câu này nó
sai
lấy hết tất cả các cột mà bộ một cái thì
ghi sao ạ Mình đã từng cha con này và
thật là không có cái điều đấy các bạn
bảo sẽ cách xa mà lấy tất cả các Cột bây
giờ giả sử là mình muốn xe lách mỗi à Có
trường hợp và snack sao thôi - mỗi cái
cột số điện thoại kiểu như này được
không kiểu như này là không trong mang
trong exel nó không hỗ trợ điều lấy nhận
các bạn phải gõ Thục thủ công ra lực và
thực tế thực tế nhá là các bạn về sau
các bạn sẽ biết là rất hạn chế dùng Surf
sao bởi vì sao Bởi vì sẽ sao nó sẽ lấy
ra tất cả các cột mà có rất nhiều cổ các
bạn không cần trong trường hợp đấy nghe
về sau các bạn sẽ không các bạn phải đi
rõ từng cầu tình của ra à Anh
ở đây đây đây có bạn trả lời mình mình
vừa nói bạn trả lời được cậu đây rồi này
học f Word và Excel khác nhiều không ạ
mình có từng nói rồi gọi đó là SS Ware
và x Excel bản chất nó cũng nón lá lại
Quest nên không khác nhau nhiều đâu nên
đã thận chỉ các bạn đã học kế toán Nói
chung là động vào nhiều ếch vết sẹo ấy
các bạn học anh queo này các bạn sẽ có
tư duy khác
đã có nhiều trường đại học Mình thấy là
có dùng câu nhưng mà dùng dâu ở để ngăn
các trại nhiều có lệnh cùng rock còn
hiện tại thì mình Bôi đen Từng dòng để
chạy nên mình sẽ không cần được chấm
phẩy để ngăn cách từng câu lệnh hay dùng
câu để ngăn cách ấy Ok mẹ trả lời hết
tất cả câu đúng không
Em
hơi cảm động và tốn hơn nửa tiếng thông
cảm các bạn
mình các bạn thông cảm mình tí tiếp theo
các công cụ thực hành đúng không Thì
ở đây nha các bạn là nếu mà các bạn theo
theo học mình từ đầu đến cuối chặng ạ
thì mình sẽ dạy về phía bên này
mai que em này sau đó là TP nó ngôn ngữ
lập trình thì các bạn sẽ nên cài shopee
hoặc lạ lala Gold mình thích mình mình
mình từng dùng shopee dùng rất lâu sau
đó nhưng gần đây mình ra công ty mới
mình biết Dragon đấy và mình chuyển qua
dùng luôn Và mình thấy ngon hơn hạ nó
tiện hơn các thứ nó không có lỗi vớ vẩn
là phạt ở bên shopee nhưng mà
nói chung là mình khuyên các bạn dùng
Dragon hơn nàng shopee rất nhiều nhưng
mà nhiều trường trường cũ mình dạy và
thấy á Nó có vẻ dễ cài đặt hơn ở shopee
có vẻ dễ Cài đặt xem nào lo con em các
bạn tí Các Bạn cân nhắc thì các bạn dùng
nhé
cho con Hưng
tiếp theo là
mày có shop cái que và cái thứ mình nó
dậy thì các bạn sẽ phải cài hai cái đó
là SQL Server
các bạn nên tải cái này để tải cái này
và cài trước bởi vì nó rất nặng và thêm
một cái nữa là à đây có bạn hôm trước
không cần nói Các bạn nhìn thấy cái đấy
rồi đó là à fco server management studio
này lại
nãy mình gì đấy Mình không nhớ viết đầy
đủ lắm
đấy studio này
cái fg Server này chỉ là cái để mà chạy
ra để mà lưu Excel trong đấy và lưu data
bay trong đấy Còn cái này là cái cái
phần mềm để mà mình thao tác với cái ra
đây đấy à à xe tải hai cái này mình biết
thôi Còn những cái những cái amwell khác
thì mình sẽ không dậy này mình cũng sẽ
không biết để xuất các bạn với cả chưa ạ
a tiếp theo à
từ những cụ có lệnh của pháp cơ bản cr-v
Nếu mà bạn thắc mắc sau đây là gì thì
thời gian ấy là các bạn cho Google sẽ ra
rồi đúng không CRD là viết tắt của trans
update Hà Đông
cd-cr đúng không
splash free
update Delete
cái này nếu dịch nó là da mình nó sẽ là
thêm mới này đọc này à Đọc lấy ra ấy
cập nhật này và xóa đấy à
ở cái gì
Ừ cái cái bài toán ở đây thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là
à Hôm trước mình đã thêm in-shop thêm mà
lấy nó ra rồi này và hôm nay mình sẽ thử
Ai
Cập nhật và xóa đúng không ạ
Ừ cái gỗ Quan Âm thì sao ạ quan thì mình
có nghe qua rồi ngoan vẫn được bạn nhé
Ừ anh mạnh tuấn đâu anh Mạnh Tuấn đang ở
ngay đây này anh gửi anh
soi sẽ mình dậy như thế nào nhưng mà anh
ấy ít khi lên tiếng lắm nên các bạn cũng
không không hi vọng mình giờ đây sẽ nghe
được điệu cười của anh ấy ạ
ừ ừ
à à
Anh Quốc Bân Đúng rồi gobin chuyên
chuyên máy kéo được đấy nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà mình nhớ không lầm là những
cái những cái công cụ chuyên kia hình
như là nó vẫn phải có một cái A cái sợ
vợ ảo để chạy thì nó vẫn cần soompi hoa
quả lạ elago là hoặc là đa cơ quan để mà
mở cái server Ảo lên mà nghỉ à
à à
Ê mấy ông bác đồ đi hơi hơi lạc đề rồi
bắt đầu hỏi là tại sao anh Tuấn đã thử
hơi hơi lạc đề rồi à anh đợi
Anh không cần biết anh ấy ở đâu đâu mày
Tạm thời như thế à
Ừ
thôi mình tạm tập trung là dạy không
mình để cái tráp nhiều quá Mình sẽ bị
phân tâm đấy
Bây giờ mình sẽ tối ưu một tí về cái hôm
trước mình đã dậy nhé mỗi buổi xong mỗi
buổi có bạn sẽ nhận ra là gần như mình
sẽ xóa hết toàn bộ cốt cũ để mà học cái
mới những các bạn cũng sẽ thấy đừng ngạc
nhiên khi mã code hôm trước khác cô hôm
nay nhé ạ
ừ ừ
à à tay tại sao mình phải nói xóa đi vì
bây giờ giả sử mình Các bạn thấy là
thông tin của anh Tuấn Nam Định Lào tại
hai lần như này trắng ạ đúng không Bây
giờ sự mình muốn xóa xóa cái dữ liệu
thừa đi không thì mình sẽ xóa người ấy
dựa trên cái gì nếu mà dựa trên tên hay
ở tuổi thì về các bạn hai thằng này
giống hệt nhau thì làm sao mà xóa được
đúng không có bạn sẽ thấy số Hải đây em
chị ạ Mình sẽ xóa rằng ở vị trí thứ hai
thôi đúng không Nhưng mà không thể lấy
được thằng thứ hai này quan trọng như
thế thì mình sẽ xóa một cách nào đúng
không quan trọng như thế
thì thường là để mà phân biệt nhau dụ
phân biệt sinh viên với nhau ấy đôi khi
mình không phân biệt có tên mà mình phải
phân biệt con mã đúng không mã sinh viên
khi bé gần nhất thứ hai là mã này phải
tránh việc lặp lại mã của sinh viên này
không được chung với sinh viên kia cũng
như ai Phải có mã đúng không mã này có
thể số hoặc chữ mình thường ngay cho nó
mặc định là số đi thì mạnh số ví dụ là
01234 đúng không Thì sẽ ra số nguyên
không cần lại số số thập phân làm gì cả
à còn các bạn muốn chữ thì các bạn Thể
tra như thế này họ tao đâu Vậy hoặc à
Vespa đúng không
Đấy đấy Cái thứ nhất thì ra là cắm ạ về
thiết kế Zombie các bạn không cần phải
ghi lại
Anh tên của bạn và trong tên cột như này
đấy thế nên là mình sẽ xóa cái cột à sẽ
sửa lại cái cục tiền chị ngắn gọn nghe
thôi thì chưa đi
xe tải và mình như mình vừa nói là muốn
cho cái mã này tránh việc nó bị lặp lại
này kết hợp với việc là nó sẽ là duy
nhất là tránh chung đấy thì nó sẽ có
khái niệm khóa chính Sạc qua wiki mã
chưa
ừ ừ
xe tải nó sẽ không được lặp lại
các bạn nó sẽ tránh chung và
vì ai Bây giờ mình sẽ thử lúc cái thấy
bồ đi này sau đó thì tạm ok rồi nó chạy
ôm thôi Sau đó thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ
thấy ở đây nó lỗi vì không cột này đúng
không Mình sẽ điền một mã này có tên này
ở đây mình sẽ có mã là một này mã là hay
đó thì anh sớm nhé
ô ô nở mau chạy này đó thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là nó ra thông tin như này bơ mìn
xuất lại phát nữa mà sẽ báo lỗi bởi vì
nó báo lỗi liên quan đến phe Mickey này
bạn sinh viên này là lặp lại cái giá trị
mụn ngon tất cả mã này lặp lại nó lỗi
bây giờ sự là mình đổi nó là 3 và đây là
bố nhận nặng thì các bạn sẽ thấy đi
trước việc bình thường bởi vì mã nó
Không lặp lại đúng không ạ Và bây giờ
mình muốn ra sự bị xóa sinh viên theo mã
thì sao mình sẽ
mình sẽ là Delete
Chrome sinh viên Này
Where mã bằng 3 xã nào
ở đó
Ừ thì ở đây sẽ Khái niệm và xóa và lấy
lấy từ trong bạn sinh viên ngon Cái này
Thực ra là vì rất ít bạn giữ đi bạn ạ Để
ý cái vụ này
đó là tự nhiên ở đây có chữ for vào đây
có chữ Ford bởi vì sao cái này lấy thông
tin ra để mà xóa lại đơn giản thế thôi
con ăn sốt thì không có cần lấy thông
tin gì ở đâu ra cả nhưng mà không cần
thêm chữ Ford và chiếc bạc còn bây giờ
một Lấy thông tin từ trong bạn sinh viên
A để xóa nó đi thì mình sẽ có khái niệm
work well as mã Nếu mà không có quen này
thì sao là sự trải như thế này thôi thì
sao Nếu chạy như thế này thì sẽ hiểu là
xóa hết tất cả các bạn về chưa vì sao
mình thử select lại thì bạn sẽ thấy
không còn gì nữa còn đưa tụi nó sát lại
này
Anh chỉ sợ lại sẽ lách để xem này 34
đúng không Bây giờ Delete foward ba này
select này sẽ chỉ còn 4 thôi được ngon
đấy
à à
anh ở đây có trường hợp là giả sử là các
bạn muốn
cho Ice sốt vào mà có bạn không phải
nhập mã Giả sử bây giờ có nhiều sinh
viên quá mình phải nhớ mã từng sinh viên
mà mình muốn nó tự động Tam thì mình làm
như thế nào là sự thế đúng không Thì
mình sẽ là mình sẽ tặng lốp thấy bổ đi
nhá Vợ mình sẽ có khái niệm làm sẽ
truyền identity
vào trong cục Mã
ý là để nó tự động tăng đấy trưa
tại bên mình sẽ thử
xe tải Bẻ cụt mã thì mình không điện
không điện được nữa đối với FTP server
mình sẽ không điện nữa mình thử nhập
Điền thì các bạn sẽ thấy báo lỗi này mà
không cho Điên này
bởi vì mã bây giờ nó sẽ tự động tăng rồi
các bạn không phải điền nó nữa chạy thử
này
a snack lại các bạn sẽ thấy mã tự động
toàn được chưa ạ
à à
Ừ
thì vậy
Ừ ok Ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy mã tự động
tăng và mình mình hoàn toàn đã có thể
bây giờ sẽ update sẽ cập nhật thông tin
của bạn Long này chẳng
Anh
dựa theo mã của bạn đấy được sự mình sẽ
update sinh viên này
xét tên rồi ạ bằng Long
Sky ạ Cái
whey mã bằng hai trận
Ừ cái
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà các bạn mà không wed
theo Cài mã đúng không ạ
Ừ tao không quay theo mã thì các bạn sẽ
cập nhật đơn giản là cầm chặt hết thôi
còn nếu mà que theo mã thì nó sẽ kiểm
tra thêm một cái điều kiện nữa là xem là
cái mã này có thỏa mãn hay không rồi nó
mới cập nhật và sửa mới chạy Như này thì
bạn sẽ thấy là đổi hết cả hai thay tên
giống hệt nhau đúng không thận chứa tất
cả mọi người nên dùng giống hệt nhau ý
ở đây đây là những cái cú pháp cơ bản
các bạn cần biết lại đúng không và các
bạn sẽ thắc mắc làm thế bây giờ sự sẽ
lách này có thêm que được không Bởi vì
lại delete và update có thêm khoe được
rồi đúng không sẽ lách này có thêm có
nghe được và nói chung là nó sẽ rất ổn
không chỉ những lò So sánh bằng Như thế
này các bạn hệ So sánh ví dụ là mã lớn
hơn hay trở ngại gì này đây nghe Hiện
tại thì chẳng có bạn nào đúng không thấy
nó rớt lại con nữa này à
à à
a salad lại phát nữa thì các bạn sẽ thấy
thì nó sẽ ra đúng không
ừ ừ
chú mã có chữ mã có chữ thì mình bảo đó
là các bạn sẽ không để cậu in vào nó
không thể tự động tăng được nữa các bạn
sẽ phải nó là ba cha họ cha gì đó thì
các bạn Nhập thôi
anh không không có chuyện chữ cái tự
động tự động tăng ở ở trong kia nó không
hỗ trợ điều đấy các bạn sẽ phải lập
trình thủ công người đoạn đấy à
em à ok đấy các bạn sẽ thấy là insta Rex
update Delete nó toàn bộ là kiến thức cơ
bản trong bộ hôm nay
để xem còn thêm kiến thức nào nữa không
nghỉ à
xe máy tên tương đối Hôm nay anh gần như
là nó cũng sẽ thương rồi thế Ờ
à à Quest chỉ dùng cho coi Mickey thôi à
Thấy câu này giữa hai này ra sửa là các
bạn Không Không cái không phải liên quan
đến mỗi mã nhá mà các bạn hoàn toàn hệ
sẽ rách theo tên bằng mong này chẳng hạn
vẫn lấy được nhé Đây
A và các bạn muốn lấy được nhiều nhiều
kiểm tra thêm nhiều điều kiện nữa tao
sửa là mình có thể dùng en khái niệm e
này trong trong này nghĩa là nó bằng nó
kẹo tương đương hai cái bên trái đúng và
bên phải cũng thấy đúng là sợ là em giới
tính bằng 1 chàng lại
thì vừa các bạn sẽ thấy vẫn ra đúng
không Nhưng mà đội nó giới tính bằng
không thì các bạn sẽ thấy không ra nữa
bởi vì xa của bia tên bằng lắm thì đúng
là có một bạn tên bằng năm rồi nhưng mà
giới tính của không thể bằng không đúng
không Thì nó sẽ không ra gì cả ý
á nhon mã có chữ thì bắt buộc phải khai
báo kiểu
tra tạo mã kiểu Loan Đu má kiểu dáng đun
thì cứ nhờ tạo được nhưng mà cái này
không phải là trong axwell nó hỗ trợ các
bạn mà các bạn sẽ phải lập trình cái
điều đấy à
à à
từ
lúc tạo bà không có không xét vai wiki
thì các bạn sẽ phải một lá nhưng mình
lúc đầu nói là một làm các bạn dùng lốp
nhưng mà về sau không nên góp để vì nó
Xóa hết toàn bộ thông tin hay các bạn sẽ
dùng enter
enter table để cùng ca bản app like gì
đấy trưa
thì à Bạn tìm hiểu về cái đây từ khóa
nhé enter
table bị lỗi SQL này app Prime kia đó
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ ra linh linh mà để các
bạn học tập thường này trên w3school này
bạn tra nhé
thì nó sẽ có khái niệm enter Table And
like in như này được Toàn thêm mới đúng
rồi có bạn hỏi rất hay của o em O O là
để mà một cái bên trái đúng hoặc bên
phải là đúng và chạy được là sự trong
trường hợp này họ sẽ thấy tên bằng mong
là đúng đúng không còn giới tính là là
sai đúng không Nhưng mà chị bên trái
Đúng là được rồi bên phải
em không cần quan tâm đều lấy nữa không
Và thực tế là cái này cái này nhóm nó
lại với nhau bằng dấu ngoặc tròn là sửa
các bạn kiểm tra như này
vào các bạn em thêm một phen được như
thế này em tuổi bắt buộc phải là 23 sẽ
lại đây nó sẽ ra
ở tuổi trong trường hợp này bắt buộc
phải bằng 23 nghĩa à Cái bên trái này
bắt buộc 1 trong 2 cái phải đúng
A và ở bên phải này chắc chắn là đúng
đúng kiệm đấy các bạn sẽ thấy là đoạn
này nó lằng nhằng hơn một tí bài tập
mình sẽ đưa các bạn để các bạn làm về
mình cái vụ này nhiều cho nó quen thì
chưa đi
à à
à
À đúng rồi nhắc với tuổi tuổi thì à
ở tuổi chị các bạn Thực tế là các bạn
không nên lưu trữ ở trong dp tuổi mà các
bạn nên lưu ngày sinh hoặc cả năm sinh
sự trong trường hợp này là 5A ngày sinh
đi
ngày sinh thì các bạn phải lưu dạng bếp
như này ở đây chưa ngày sinh nhật bạn
lưu dọn bếp
A và
ngày sinh lưu ở trong này nó sẽ là năm
tháng
ngày chưa là sự là 1997 này 0101 này đấy
à
à à
thì các bạn sẽ phải lưu lại ngày sinh
như này Tại sao các bạn lưu ảnh ngày
sinh hay vì lưu lại tuy rằng tuổi chứ
lại thì hiển thị ra mình anh hơn đúng
không còn ngày sinh thì các bạn sẽ phải
ngồi đến mà người đến bao nhiêu tuổi em
ạ đúng không cộng trừ nhân chia thì anh
bị không giải Toán đúng không Thì cái vụ
đẩy để cho ngôn ngữ Lập trình về sau các
bạn làm nó sẽ hỗ trợ để tính ra được tủa
chính xác Xem người đấy bây giờ băng
đang bao nhiêu tuổi đã qua sinh nhật
thầy chưa để mà tình yêu tuổi còn không
thì chuẩn các bạn vẫn sẽ phải lưu lại
ngày sinh với sao vì cứ mỗi lần mỗi sau
mỗi năm điều hòa sau mỗi sinh nhật của
bạn đấy thì các bạn lại phải là đã tới
bảy cần nhật tôi á đúng không sự bây giờ
hiện tại mình đang đi trước là 23 tuổi
sau đó đi về sang năm mới qua sinh nhật
của mình thì bạn lại phải vào sửa đặt
cho bầy hoàn thành 2 tư ạ Không đúng
không sẽ rất mất công thì nên các bạn sẽ
phải lưu lại những cái gì mà
à
vì sau nó thay đổi liên tục đúng không
Mình phải tính toán các thứ thứ ừ ừ
Em có cách nào để hiển thị giới tính là
nam nữ mà vẫn dùng bit đúng có bản chất
là lưu lại cảnh giới tính như này cũng
giống như mình vừa nói cái vụ là mình
lưu lại ngày sinh lý thì các bạn in ra
lại là tuổi chứ không phải ra ngày sinh
trưởng ạ thì cái này ở bên con ngôn ngữ
lập trình các bạn sẽ là thời gian trong
FeO nó cũng hỗ trợ để mà nó phải tính
toán nhanh để in ra cho quán nhanh nhưng
cái này sẽ là ép Wow chuyên sau một tí
Mình sẽ nói sau A
à à
tủ bếp bàn bếp không bay ra sự ngày sinh
3 lấy lưu một tí Nếu các bạn Nhập ngày
sinh thì có bạn sẽ không nhập số kiểu
kiểu dạng lại như này được
không Không nhập như này được Kiểu nghe
được nha và sẽ bảo nó sẽ báo lỗi đấy các
bạn sẽ phải cho nó mới trong chuỗi được
chưa Cho dù nó to nó số nhưng thực ra nó
lại có ký tự chuỗi có ký tự này rồi Ông
nói là chú ếch
anh nó sẽ như thế này được chưa
ở thời sự là anh Tuấn sinh năm 2000
ạ đấy à
à à
em
Có nên tắt first name và last name được
bể một tí ra hay là sự là với với bên
nước ngoài thì sẽ có last name và first
name còn của mình thường hay gộp chung
và là họ và tên đúng không Nhưng mà
nhiều nhiều nôi Mình thấy có hẳn rõ ra
là ví dụ là do sự họ giâm so ngồi tên
riêng rồi tên đệm riêng nữa là sự thế hệ
như thế này riêng nó nữa đi này Nếu phân
biệt như này thì càng tốt để mà về sau
các bạn Ware theo cái tên đấy Jack welch
tên như thế này nó sẽ rất là ổn đúng
không ạ
Ừ nhưng mà đường nhiên lúc này in ra để
chị ra thì các bạn đã phải mất thêm một
cái đoạn xử lý là các bạn phải nối nó
lại để đầy đủ họ và tên đúng không ạ
có cách nào để FeO kết nối để ngôn ngữ
lập trình thì cái này các bạn khi mà học
đề ngôn ngữ lập trình thì các bạn sẽ
biết được cái đưa nhé
và đây Bây giờ mình sẽ thu snack ngày
sinh vừa nãy đúng không Thì cũng sẽ được
nặn que thôi thì chưa về nhà được và
đương nhiên là cái cũng giàu nhỏ hơn
hoặc lớn hơn được ạ như thế à
chỉ cách viết ghi chú comment Ok các bạn
hỏi rất nhiều câu rất ổn đấy chứ cái
viết ghi chú thì một là các bạn dùng
trong này thì nữa không có thang nó sẽ
ra kiểu
dùng hay hay dấu trừ như thế này để mà
ghi chú nhé thì các bạn sẽ thấy màu thay
đổi chú thích ở trong lập trình nó khá
là quan trọng của vì đôi khi các bạn
không muốn bạn cốt để chạy các bạn Bôi
đen rất nhiều cái nhưng mà đơn giản lại
không muốn ra ngoài chạy thì các bạn sẽ
truyền đó anh chú thích ngay thôi chưa ạ
thì tại sao dùng qua bên kia ở đây nhá
cái khái niệm của ipkiss mình sẽ nhắc
lại thêm một lần nữa sau nhà Bây giờ
trước mắt kia nó dịch ra là khóa chính
đúng không hóa chính
và dùng để phân biệt
các bản nghi với nhau còn nói còn nói
trong cụ thể trường hợp này dùng để phân
biệt các sinh viên vào nhau thôi đúng
không các sinh viên với nhau bởi vì tên
thôi là chưa đủ
ờ và cái quan trọng ở đây là không chỉ
để mỗi phân biệt mà là
bởi vì có khái niệm đây mình sẽ nói qua
luôn đấy các bạn lên trang của mình sẽ
thấy có Yoona cũng là là để tránh trùng
tránh lặp lại Nó nhanh bằng like I là
việc là cũng để không cho ở lại Bản đi
bắt buộc phải được duy nhất
nhưng mà sự khác biệt giữa quạt Mickey
với unique đó là quay Mickey nó không
được phép luôn
bay thì bằng unix + lót luôn cái việc
nôn nôn là gì Thì bây giờ mình sẽ thử nó
luôn tranh thủ mà luôn các bạn hãy luôn
ở trong lập trình rất nhiều người ra Dễ
nhầm À đây
Ý là mình sẽ dùng cái ảnh này ví dụ của
bạn
Ừ mình rất thích cái ảnh này
anh ở đây Cái này nó thấy hơn
à à
anh phải các bạn sẽ thấy Đây nhá Ờ
ở đây là có có một giá trị gì đấy này
không trứng gà trống này
không không có chồng mới được mong nun
là nó còn
mà nó còn không phải là không luôn nói
chuyện đơn giản là nó chưa từng xuất
hiện chỉ có thế còn còn andyfat là nó nó
chưa được khai báo chưa từng tồn tại
Ừ cái này nó rất dễ loạn ở trong lập
trình cực kỳ loạn Các bạn nhìn hình xong
các bạn hiểu em không đúng không các bạn
học lập trình xong các bạn sẽ hình dung
na ná được đấy ngày Các bạn nhớ hình ảnh
này Các nó dễ những lời chúc mà luôn này
có bạn hiểu là nó như thế này à Mình có
một cốc nước thì uống hết nước rồi thì
cái cốc này là bây giờ nó thành đơn giản
nó thấy nước thức là nó nước của nó ở
trong cốc có băng không đúng không Nhưng
mà giả sử mình có một cốc nước chưa từng
có nước thì
cho nước nó không phải bằng không mà nó
đơn giản đó chưa từng được đổ nước thôi
gà con
vì mình không có cả cốc nước thì nó sẽ
bằng ăn mì file kẻ nifa về sau các bạn
học mình ra speak thì các bạn gặp nhiều
hơn
nhưng mà còn kể không mày luôn nó rất dễ
nhiều người nhầm nhưng mà bây giờ giải
thích các bạn nó là nào giống như này là
sử mình nhập tên vào ngực tên sinh viên
vào
nhưng mình nhập mình nhập tên kiểu nhà
đi
ở đây à
khi nhập tên sinh viên là như thế này đi
nhập trống luôn không có cái gì cả
khu resort này
à à cột ngày sinh
ngày sinh đúng mà
Em à anh như mình chưa giúp bạn đi nó
bạn đi
quét lại
à à ta0 Anh Mình mình tạm xóa tạm họ và
tên đệm cho nó dễ nhận nhé Nó lại phát
nữa này
ở Nhật tên này các bạn thấy là nhập tên
chấm vẫn nhận được đúng không Đúng chưa
thử Similac này
Ừ đấy các bạn thấy tên đang là trống
đúng không ừ ừ
Anh tên chuyển giàn lá nó là chấm chứ
không phải là nó không có giá trị là
không phải móc đúng rồi không phải nói
nó chưa từng được nhập nó được nhập rồi
nhưng nó là nó thôi Cái này bắt đầu hơi
đau não hội I
Ừ đúng rồi là na ná giống như kiểu các
bạn nói thất tình thất tình nghĩa là có
người yêu rồi nhưng mình mất đấy thì nó
biến anh không đúng chưa Nhưng mà nói em
FA là kẹo Forever Alone nghĩa chưa từng
có người yêu thì nó là lùn đấy
anh cũng con còn trong đầu các bạn chưa
từng biết khái niệm người yêu là gì thì
nó sẽ ra đi file
đây là phải ví dụ như thế các bạn với
tường được đó à
ăn gì chưa
anh FA là polvilho đúng không chưa từng
có miếu thì nó sẽ ăn luôn bây giờ
ơi con có người yêu rồi mà thất tình họ
bị nó đá đúng không chia tay thì nó sẽ
về không chưa
khi con còn chưa biết người yêu là cái
gì nó sẽ ăn mì Pha Ra Ông nào không hiểu
ví dụ đấy nữa thì thì nó cũng là ăn gì
phải đấy ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ
đúng rồi thật ra mình quên mất các bạn
là sinh viên các bạn vẫn đang tuổi À thì
ra mình cũng đang tuổi trẻ trâu thôi
nhưng mình không nhạy cảm với vấn đề để
đến thế chứ bên nhắc về vấn đề đấy nhạy
cảm nên là các bạn dễ nhớ hơn
khi thầy đang ở trong tình trạng nào
ẩm thực tế có một sự thật đó là con
người ta không ngờ có gì là chắc chắn ổn
định nên là tùy ở mình mình đưa không
còn là nôn nữa nhưng mà mình có thể về
không bất cứ lúc nào
từ
điển hình vợ bật dậy đứng dậy xong rồi
hô to một tiếng rồi nó khi bay lắm à
à à
Ừ ok kiến thức của hôm nay thực ra nó
không hiểu chủ yếu là trả lời câu hỏi
các bạn nhiều hơn nhưng mà bài tập mình
hôm nay cũng sẽ có rất rất nhiều người
phụ vui tí là như thế mình sẽ
chị sẽ có rất nhiều câu hỏi để các bạn
làm Bởi vì không đi thứ ba mà đúng không
Thứ bảy thì bạn sẽ
anh còn tận mấy ngày nữa để các bạn làm
nên làm bài tập hôm nay mình sẽ có rất
nhiều
gọi rất nhiều hơi quá Nhưng nói chung là
chết là nhiều hơn ông trước rồi hôm
trước ở chị có những trắc nghiệm cho vui
Hôm nay sẽ có phải trắc nghiệm và cả bài
tập cốt để các bạn phải cốt chưa ạ
à à
em có bạn vừa khỏi câu rất hay kìa lấy
một lấy sinh viên theo tháng thì sao
những cái câu đấy mình chưa dậy mà mình
sẽ cho bài tập để cho các bạn tra Google
đã
ạ bây giờ bài tập sẽ có câu cơ bản và
câu hơi hơi sao Bà có cả câu sau hẳn ông
ông nào mà mà đang hiểu biết một tí gì
vào đây nghe của tôi thì ông thử làm mấy
câu sao hạn của tôi xem ông làm được
không đấy
đấy để để cho các bạn việc tra Google
các bạn phải tra Còn không thì có bạn
chỉ làm được câu cơ bản thôi câu sao sao
một tí cả các bạn phải trao Google rồi
còn câu sau hàm thì các bạn việc
Vietravel các bạn phải giữ là tốt cũng
như là các bạn phải có một tí kinh
nghiệm tại đây chưa ạ
ờ ờ Tại sao nên học Apple ở mình quên
đấy Cảm ơn bạn nhé
affairs này thì K là mình nói qua là chủ
ra nó rất rộng nó bên bác em cần lên kế
toàn cần này cần biết cần biết thì tốt
hơn đấy con
còn bên Bát Đen Tại sao cầm thì là bởi
vì là làm bất kỳ cái gì bây giờ cũng đều
phải động với dữ liệu thì cái này để
truy vấn dữ liệu này ra nặn thôi và để
không phải truy vấn nữa mà để xử lý dữ
liệu luôn đi
ừ ừ
khi FBI và Doctor thì nên dùng cái nào
hơn thế hãy nhớ bạn hơi nhầm lẫn rồi cái
khái niệm buồn vì ở đó cơ Mình nhớ không
lần là nó khác mà cho hai cái thằng nó
hơi không liên quan gì nhau lắm đấy à
hơi tách biệt kiểu kiểu Ý
khi học xong khóa của mình thì làm được
gì ạ bởi cậu lạnh giữa hai này ờ
Ừ chắc chắn an toàn bộ Nếu mà học xong
mỗi Apple này thì đầu đầu video mà mình
nói rồi còn nếu mà học xong tất cả cái
cùng mình dậy thì các bạn sẽ về cơ bản
cái đầu tiên các bạn làm được làm một
trang web cơ bản đã cái thứ hai là các
bạn ghét web thì các bạn có thể nhảy
sang được làm những cái khác liên quan
đến Lập trình về áp hay lập trình duyệt
và trình vệ ứng dụng
ứng dụng máy tính áp điện thoại sự điện
thoại ngon nếu mà các bạn muốn nghiện
game Giống mình thế thử là cũng mong
muốn lúc đầu sẽ làm được trình game ý
thì ca lập trình game thì con thêm yêu
to tố giỏi toán đã thực ra còn nhiều thứ
nữa nhưng mà vẫn cần ngôn ngữ lập trình
thế nên là các bạn vẫn không thừa ngày
của mẹ vi này nó 2 điểm đấy Nó kiểu có
học xong một cái các bạn đá ra người
khác nó vẫn nó vẫn tốt đấy Anh kém lắm
vẫn được các bạn chỉ cần học thêm thôi
các bạn không thấy kiến thức là bị thừa
để cái điểm ra là hay nhưng mà Chính vì
nó hay Chính vì nó rộng như thế nên các
bạn sẽ dễ bị choáng thì thôi
I
Swear và mongodb thì nên chọn cái nào ạ
anh em Thứ nhất là nó sẽ dễ hơn nó với
que cái
đấy theo mình nhé Còn và nó phụ biến hơn
em còn muốn Golden b thì đúng à Nó cũng
có rất nhiều cái u ư
khi IP iPad điện cái này lại kiến thức
hơi xa quá mất rồi như là mình nghĩ ở
trong buổi các bạn sẽ không đề cập tới
đây những cái câu hỏi mình có đọc hết
tất cả câu hỏi nhá Mình vẫn để ý mình là
kiểm duyệt của nhóm chưa tycông ty mà
mình đọc tất cả bình luận và vì tất cả
thì chưa để mà biết ông nào còn Dell
treak để hạ xử đúng không Thế nên là có
rất nhiều câu hỏi các bạn Mình có đọc
nho Mình không trả lời không phải vì bơ
hay là khó quá không chơi được
em tính của mình và giảm nào dám nhận và
có gì chị sẽ lấy có những cả mình không
chờ được mình sẽ nói mình bảo mình không
nên chắc mình có nói có những câu mà
mình không trả lời đôi khi là bởi vì nó
không
chứ không phải là câu phổ biến thì sẽ
còn mọi người cùng nghe mình có thể trả
lời riêng hoặc là
hoặc là nó kẹo nó Nó kiểu không nằm
trong cái Phạm Viên buổi họp đấy mình sẽ
không trả lời à
à à
a p p v thường đi với FeO không phải
móng vô bởi vì vốn dĩ là thằng ngu vì
người sinh ra sau đây mà vẫn cả đã pp nó
đúng là mai kia nó hỗ trợ rất mạnh với
pp ở đây là hai thằng thằng ấy đi cùng
với nhau đi
A codeless có fan rất là phổ biến để mặt
tạo ra website website bây giờ đến 70
phần trăm là tạo từ mấy cái kiểu
gọi là flashform bằng postgrad với Sơn
La 2 vân vân vân Nhưng mà thực tế là
mình học lập trình thì mình không nên
theo cái bên đấy bên đấy là nó gần như
Tôn kéo thả hơn vì nên kiểu mình làm
hoàn toàn bằng cốc thì ổn hơn
ừ ừ
khi người ta dùng phần mềm gì để cốt cốt
mày cái phần mềm kiểu lập trình cho xi
cộng Thì cái phần mềm gì mà cốt được rất
nhiều cái thứ nhất mình thấy con nhận
vẫn là Visual Studio code đi rùa cha
mình thấy K toàn không nhớ tên thôi Tại
Visual Studio code Cái này hỗ trợ rất
nhiều gõ rất nhiều ngôn ngữ lập trình
Ngồi viết Cốt lại ngon
Ừ xong SQL có nói thêm việc publish
không không thực tế là tên bốc phét gần
đây mình có độc ở công ty nhưng mà mình
chưa đủ kiến thức để mọi dậy các bạn nên
là mình chắc là Apple Server này xong
mình sẽ sang p rồi nhắc lại về f-word
theo kiểu mái với out chúng mình không
dậy bên quét được
ừ ừ
Ừ cái đấy thì mình vừa nói đấy nghĩa là
các bạn cũng sẽ phải biết bên Mai ép kéo
Ừ đúng rồi hồi trước mình phát sinh viên
mình cốt hết bằng nút phát đây Tại sao
tại sao mình dùng cái này được mà mình
dùng một lúc bác
kiểu quay lại thời tiền sử hả không Bởi
vì a mình muốn chứng minh cho sinh viên
thầy đấy à thực ra các bạn không cần cái
gì cũng được nghĩa là sao đương nhiên
các bạn phải kết nối đến đã tôi bây để
chạy còn bạn cốt bằng cái gì cũng được
trả qua cái này nó không có gợi ý của nó
rất là thô tục Ôi đúng không Các bạn có
thể code bằng word hay cái gì cũng được
Xin chào tất cả chị gõ lệnh ra gõ từ bàn
phím ra thôi các bạn chạy nhưng mà đúng
không
ừ ừ
anh vs Tại sao anh không dùng vé cốt
dùng vs code thì tự nhiên là mình ông
anh ở công ty của mình là người ra mình
nhiều nhất là cái việc khốc này nó hơi
bị ỉa
có liên quan đến cắm tính cá nhân một tí
để chuyện riêng Tí nó đại lại liên quan
vụ thất tình thế mình sẽ không
nhưng mình vẫn sẽ khuyến khích các bạn
chứ không phải là mình ghét nó lỗi vì
chúng mình nhắc về nữa
à à có bạn vừa nãy anh nói chọn nhiều
tên thì dùng que tên in trong SG được
không vậy Bạn gõ như thế thì nó là ra
đáp án rồi đấy đúng không Đây để cái mà
bạn em vẫn nói rất là hai ví dụ là sự
mình muốn tên nằm trong cái danh sách dù
Long này chẳng hạn
anh phải chạy Tôi tin là chạy thử sẽ
rách sao cho mình có những tên gì anh
nhé Anh cũng nút bên rồi à Ok xử với em
nhìn xót lòng này
Ok này
Tuấn đây ah
ở
đây Nếu mình sẽ rách sao ra thì các bạn
sẽ thấy là nó sẽ ra 33 bạn này nhưng mà
bây giờ mình chỉ muốn lấy tên một là
Long hay là tuấn Thôi thì mình sẽ dùng
tên long otane bằng Tuấn đúng không
Đây một cách này à
à à Em ngủ chưa
Ừ đúng rồi nhỉ Đúng rồi thì chị nào nữa
quên quên
ở đây Ok ngủ ngon hay là có bạn vừa bảo
nếu mà trong trường hợp o như này nhiều
thì mình nên nằm nó trong một cái danh
sách và sẽ là khái niệm y nằm trong một
cái danh sách đấy thưa cái này là kiến
thức
anh cũng không hẳn ở cơ bản nên là mình
mười chưa dậy nhé bạn hỏi thì mình cứ
trả lời để bạn là thắc mắc hoặc cả hoặc
các bạn các bạn làm bài tập kiểu gì tí
mình sẽ ra mà thì các bạn sẽ in là nằm
trong một cái danh sách nào đó như thế
này được chưa bằng cách nhau bởi dấu
phẩy và đơn như phải nằm trong ngoặc
tròn này nó sẽ như này đó và thực tế nếu
các bạn biện bên Chuyến sau về SQL thì
liên quan bạn chọn tối ưu thích thì phải
y này nó nhanh hơn kẻo vừa rồi nên là
mình khuyên là các bạn nên dùng y như
thế nào ạ
ừ ừ
à à
ở
ngã tự nhiên mày ông ấy khuyên tôi kệ
chuyện thất tình ở trên này à
ô hay thôi
à à
ở các lệnh B nasware này có giọng được
Excel và Google Map từ có mạng Google
mít thì mình nhớ Không làm vuông Mỹ hơi
sai người có cùng đít là cái cái mà ý
các bạn vào Google sheet đúng không
Excel Google sheet thì tự nhiên mình có
ai cập rồi lái xe Hoàng chất nó cũng
giống were này là các bạn học em này
xong sang làm kế toán ngon lành à
em làm vectơ có cần giỏi este không anh
a chưa con này mày cũng trả lời ở trong
trong cái video này gửi các bạn nên đây
Đầy thực không bị nhược điểm một tí đấy
ở 100 do mình không nên mình muốn một
cái buổi học không nên quá dài thì các
bạn sẽ bị lười Xem lại video Và đôi khi
mình
tính mình nghỉ được là hơi bị ghét cánh
vụ nhất lại nhắc lại đi nhắc lại lại em
sẽ mãi quên đấy à
thì các bạn khó mà nhắc lại được một câu
chuyện cười đầy đủ ba bốn lần nó kiểu
rồi Thế nó sẽ bị ăn bớt và nó sẽ bị mất
đi cái cái cảm xúc lần đầu khi các bạn
nói nên là mình muốn mua cái ví dặm mua
cái bụi là nó rất là ngắn và các bạn có
thể xem lại xem lại
anh Đương nhau có thể tua nhưng mà Nên
xem lại Bởi vì toàn bộ những cái đôi khi
mình trả lời có khó hết ở trong cái
video rồi
về ngôn ngữ đầu tiên mình học
Ừ mình Họ Pascal ở trường cấp 3 mình
cũng là một trong những kẻ tham nhũng
kiểu con nhà người ta theo kiểu lạ mình
mình gánh cả lớp cả lớp ngồi chơi kiểu
kiểu thế xô rồi đấy mình cũng chuyên cả
bến Excel
thế nhưng nhưng mà kiểu có đấy thì mình
học không phải là để mà theo cái ngành
này ra là mình thấy ra nó chẳng những gì
khó mà
anh em mình cứ hấp thôi
ở
câu lạc bộ lập trình của anh còn hoạt
động không ạ Có bạn nghe dịch vụ câu lạc
bộ lập trình của mình ở bên trường của
mình mình có mở câu lạc bộ lập trình
thì à à
ở câu lạc bộ của mình gần đây à À đây
phải nhắc Tí về toán nó hơi cái này
không lạc đề đó nhá Nó vẫn đúng chậm đâm
này lại mình nó em ạ
có thai của mình đã từng nói ở trên lớp
của mình đó là các bạn sẽ nghe khái niệm
20 80 nhiều 20 80 là gì Là hai mươi phần
trăm số người sẽ thành công hơn 80 phần
trăm số người còn lại ở bất kỳ đâu trong
tập thể nghĩa là
cho ví dụ là lớp mình có
i10 bạn à có 40 bạn thì hai mươi phần
trăm là
95 là 8 bạn phá bạn trong đó sẽ rất giỏi
hơn tất cả người còn lại
tại sao tự nhiên nhìn là 20 tháng 10 ở
đây bởi vì À cái này nó hơi bị đúng kiểu
dạng áp dụng cho câu lạc bộ mình cho vợ
bộ mình mình ạ
Mình kêu gọi ở trên cái nhóm Facebook là
500 thành viên lên đấy Thì đúng 1/5 là
100 người truy cập vào trong cải Linh
this code của mình để học câu lạc bộ lớp
9 sau đó thì trong đúng 100 người đấy có
mỗi hai người 20 người học xơi trong
Đúng 20 người học đấy cùng 14 người học
thực tế và on thường xuyên và học giỏi
nó đúng kiểu 28 10 luôn Ồ vãi chưởng thế
nên là mình tin cái khoảng 20 tháng 10
cực
Ê bà thực tế ở trong trong này có khi
cũng thế đúng không Các bạn thấy là this
code của mình của server của mình hiện
tại đang rất đông đúng không Đây thực sự
là những người học trong đó thì cũng chỉ
có khi 20 tháng 10 thật
thì và trong xong tất cả những người học
ở đây các bạn cũng sẽ có 20 80 đúng
không ạ
đó là hai mươi phần trăm số người sẽ học
và dầu trong 1 thành công hơn 80 phần
trăm người còn lại cũng chưa em
ơi các bạn hãy chứng minh điều điều của
mình vừa nói là sai thì các bạn có thể
học theo từ mình xem mình từ đầu đến
cuối mà lớn hơn được ba mươi phần trăm
hai cái gì vậy Tí giờ ổn không ạ
từ 20 tháng 11 lần nữa mình có gặp trong
đời thì đó là hồi mà mình làm cái cậu
chuyện này có chuyện cũng liên quan đến
công nghệ tin rồi kìa có đến mình làm
cái phần mềm ý
thì anh anh thầy của mình anh ấy bảo là
bọn anh thấy bởi vì ạ anh đấy chứ À
Người thầy đầu tiên của mình khi mà mình
mới đi làm công ty anh đấy là chủ của
website
phim bất hủ không phải là phim mời nhé
phim Bất Hủ anh đấy rất là giỏi và anh
đây
Ừ
anh đợi ý dạy mình rất nhiều thứ
Hồi đấy mình mới đi học tập mình chạy
cối gãy cái gì mình cũng hỏi Hoa đến tục
Ừ nhưng mà được ngờ cũng biết tế nhị nữa
là mình chị hỏi anh ấy cái trao Google
từ khóa nó là gì chứ mình không thể bảo
anh đấy làm từ A đến Z cho mình được
chúng mà anh đây con ngựa rất là kiên
trì với mình thế Mình xin anh để thấy ba
người từng nói mình đó lại em không nên
làm cái tính năng làm cái phần mềm mà
chỉ có hai mươi phần trăm người dùng Em
biết tại sao Xiaomi nó nổi lên không
Ừ nó nổi lên rồi vì nó đáp ứng được 80
phần trăm thị trường những người tiêu
dùng khắp và thiệu chung thay vì nó tập
trung ở hai mươi phần trăm người giàu
em chỉ làm những cái tính năng 80 phần
trăm thôi Nó bỏ qua hai mươi phần trăm
hai mươi phần trăm kia nó lại tốn thời
gian và tốn tiền bạc bằng 8 100 kia
anh
có em tôn bốn lần ấy thế này các bạn sẽ
các bạn về sau sẽ phải cứng nhắc lại như
cái vụ 20 tháng 10 ý
anh đúng không
Anh và thằng Apple thì nói ngược lại nó
lại đánh vào hai mươi phần trăm
cái người dùng nhưng mà đương nhiên là
các bạn thấy là bây giờ là
Việt Nam mình hơi bị ngược Việt Nam mình
nữa Cái kiểu ông nào cũng cầm phải khổ
có máy phone như thế nào ạ
ô tía bê bây giờ cho anh cũng tầm tầm
rồi tra là mình chuẩn bị tạm nghỉ và
mình các bạn cố tầm 10 cầm Thực ra cũng
không cần phải đến 10 giờ lao vào học
đâu nhưng mà tầm 10 giờ mình sẽ có gì sẽ
đăng hết các bài tập Chắc là thế Bây giờ
mình sẽ đang bài tập lên cái link nha
mình để trong phần mô tả link table đúng
không thì các bạn
và đấy làm mà các bạn có một cách đó là
các bạn cũng nên chia sẻ chia sẻ bạn bè
đúng không
Thực ra vừa nãy mình có
nhà mình có đi vệ sinh
hơi tế nhị thì nó địa sinh đôi khi nó
nhận ra những cái chân ái cuộc đời trong
đấy kìa mà mình nghĩ là
Ừ mình đang rất may mắn khi mà làm ngành
này vì à
Ừ mình rạch vãi cậu mình đang ngồi
dậy không công xong rồi kìa tốn bao
nhiêu thời gian cũng cũng kiểu người ra
nó như mình vui rồi nó coi như một cái
sự đang cứ cho giải trí thôi mình và Ừ
mình vẫn đang kiếm được tiền từ cái
ngành công nghệ công ty mình mình vẫn ổn
sống rất ổn thoải mái mà cái ngành công
nghệ tin mình lại đúng cái đam mê mình
nữa và mình làm việc sẽ thoải mái không
bị cản giờ giấc gì cả Hiện tại đang làm
tại nhà dịch này chả hiểu gì dịch này
còn kiểu khiến cho con cái ngành của
mình có vẻ không giỡn hơn nữa thành ra
là mình cảm thấy mình đang thoải mái vãi
để và mình lại đang dậy sinh viên mình
sợ tự nhiên lại sợ được cậu sợ sinh viên
mình giỏi quá rồi nó đi cướp việc của
mình ra nhưng mình trận ra là ngành này
à ở thị trường Vẫn đang thiếu nhiều vậy
chưa lương đãi ngộ khen thưởng thứ vẫn
anh vẫn thiếu thành ra là mình nghĩ là
ở đầu tiên là phải thị phải cho các bạn
biết được cái điều đấy đã làm thứ hai là
cho các bạn Tỉ động lực
về ngày này có cái nhìn khác này nhưng
mà chưa xong rồi các bạn Mình vẫn khẳng
định là em thấy 80 vậy chứ chắc là các
bạn đã theo được hoàn toàn cái ngành này
được
Ừ
cái này là liên quan đến năng lực nữa
đúng không nên con rất nhiều như tố nữa
Ừ nhưng mà mình muốn cho các bạn thứ
nhất là có cái nhìn khác hoàn toàn khác
về cái này không tin nó có khó nhưng mà
nó cũng rất nhiều với sướng nhiều ông
Toàn lên than cái ngành này bà khổ có
thể có sự đúng có rất nhiều cái khổ
nhưng mà ngày nào chẳng khổ đúng không
nào họ nó có cái đãi ngộ sướng thì các
bạn Để thử kể ra nha thư kể về cái lịch
của ngày hôm nay thôi Của mình thôi cháu
ạ
So sánh 10 giờ dạy họp
ăn à ngồi xếp báo là một đống bốc ngồi
sửa hụt mặt đến 1 giờ 1 giờ trường bắt
đầu ăn sáng nhưng ăn xong thì nằm ngủ
luôn ngủ đến 5:00 5 giờ dậy sau đó đi ạ
anh ở lại ngồi ăn rồi Ngồi tắm rửa xong
rồi chuẩn bị bài có thôi xong rồi Ngô
đến một chia ly từ 7 giờ đến bây giờ thì
ngồi chém gió với các bạn
ạ sau đó thì tí mới bắt đầu mới làm
khi được cất cái thoải mái tình yêu
thích mình ngồi chơi được Nếu mình làm
xong rồi đúng không Nhưng mà đương nhiên
mà có bất thì các bạn sẽ không có ngành
nào mày nghỉ không có giờ nào được nghỉ
à mà khi không có việc gì thuốc thì các
bạn làm đơn vô tư và xếp cũng sẽ yêu quý
của sếp vẫn sẽ trân trọng các bạn xếp
cho dù ghét các bạn cũng không không nỡ
mà đổi các bạn nếu bạn làm ổn
ừ ừ
anh nghe bài Hấp dẫn không mà lương cao
nhé vững mạnh nâng cao nhé Đúng không mà
sếp phải coi trọng các bạn chứ ngoài xếp
Coi các bạn như cái gì đó không sẽ rất
coi trọng các bạn hãy nói như thế
đi đái thôi có ông đi bình luận Sao em
toàn thấy chứ chưa cho ta đấy Hôm qua ví
dụ hôm qua mình có tâm trạng mình kiểu
cốt cột không vào mình ngồi chơi game
nhé nhưng mà đương nhiên là
Ờ Ờ
mình vẫn phải cả không không đền công
việc nó đun dồn đúng không ạ
à à
ở link discord bèo tặng đóng rồi bạn nha
Nhưng mà các bạn hoàn toàn đại học qua
những cái kênh
kênh online trực tiếp như này còn có bài
tập tự thử mà
Ừ
ok Nói chung à rất rất dài rồi Sao rồi
kể cả các bạn còn muốn ngồi lắng nghe
nữa thì mình vẫn cảm thấy nó đang hơi đi
xa vấn để cũng như là Ý mình bảo muốn
mua video rất là ngắn mà nó ngọt để các
bạn thể ngồi xem lại nên là tình cấp
mình sẽ tổng hợp lại tất cả có hỏi vào
buổi xong trả lời tiếp nhé Thôi mình tạm
nghỉ ở đây nhỉ à
xã hội